it's time get your ways clear your mind
breathe in breathe out
control your breathing use your [ __ ]
diaphragm
that's your pathway it's a long windy
road like that [ __ ] goofy ass rolled
over in San Francisco that's how your
[ __ ] intestines are shaped you go
through your rectum to [ __ ] vector
that's a medical term for your ass hole
let yourself fall [ __ ] away I'm gonna
take you on an amazing journey we're
gonna go [ __ ] in a body you see trust
me you don't trust me you wanna call you
in spoken [ __ ]
he was outspoken you were saying hey
[ __ ]
well [ __ ] taking me yet [ __ ]
destination we closed eyes you see a
medal and [ __ ] stream from [ __ ]
flowers and [ __ ] ah I love it it's
beautiful is trampled and then you open
your eyes you ain't in no [ __ ] mental
they know scream over there you still
[Music]
the left stream is and [ __ ] washing
machine you hit a water going in and
cutting and washing machine because that
[ __ ] couch you sleep one in that
basement
it's right next to the [ __ ] laundry
room stupid-ass brother
there's always watching his goddamn
sneakers and he dries his goddamn goofy
ass [ __ ] stinks never [ __ ] try
[Laughter]
[ __ ] sneakers oh my god your dryer
just took you out of your [ __ ] self
calm the [ __ ] down
[Music]
so to ourselves close trust a [ __ ]
process keep breathing in through your
nose
[Music]
out to your ass into your nose out to
your ass I know for the stop I stopped
breathing
[Music]